What's the worst eye ailment
that you come across?
The worst?
You know, short of something
that would kill you,
you know like what's something bad
that someone would come in
where it's like painful and gross.
Herpes.
Oh!
Wait, herpes in the eye?
Yeah.
How does that happen? Forget
it, I don't wanna know.
Yeah.
I just broke my own rule.
I don't wanna know.
Forget it, I don't wanna know how,
wow.
You have to get,
I mean, it goes in the eye, yeah.
Do eyes have sex?
(laughing)
Oh God.
This is--
A man
can give him self herpes.
Wait, seriously?
I mean, if you're gonna,
I'm sorry, but if you
have herpes on your penis
and you jizz in your eye,
then yeah, you give yourself herpes.
Jesus Christ!
Clean it up, Sona.
We don't know Sara.
This isn't us just--
That's not what I said.
She brought it up.
She brought it to this table.
This isn't us just hanging
out in the break room.
That's not happens.
So wait, how does it happen, Sara?
I'm and listen,
first of all, I apologize.
I think Sona was way out of line.
I think she used terrible language
and I don't,
and also, I don't even
understand how that happens,
a man shoots that into the air
and then like an outfielder
trying to catch a pop fly
runs underneath and it hits him.
That's how it happens.
You're trying to catch it your hands,
but the sun's in your eyes
and then it just goes right in your eyes
and then you got herpes all over.
What the?
Okay, so I'm sorry, Sara.
I can't.
Please, please inject,
please inject a little intelligence
into this conversation.
Bruno, stop.
Sorry, my dog's making crying sounds.
Oh good.
It's gonna make
the podcast now.
I'm glad. (laughing)
Your dog's objecting.
I'm glad that wasn't
He heard this.
your boyfriend or husband.
Bruno stop!
Bruno's in the background
shooting things in the air
and trying to catch them with his eye.
Oh!
Bruno!
Bruno, knock it off, we're
talking about that right now.
Stop it!
Sara, this is the worst,
worst podcast we've ever
done and it's not your fault.
I'm so glad to be part of it.
Yeah.
You did this to us.
You know what we've done.
We've done Westerly really proud.
Yeah.
I was gonna say,
I can't wait for patients to hear this and
my mom.
Man.
So eye herpes, wow, okay,
I don't want to know.
I just don't even want to know.